no hay otra solución que intensificar la
lucha armada es el principal lema del
decimosexto congreso del frente
polisario una de las últimas guerrillas
del mundo que desde 1973 lucha en el
desierto del Sáhara occidental por su
independencia desde el viernes y durante
cinco días más de 2.000 congresistas y
370 invitados internacionales se reúnen
en la cita más importante en décadas
Ese es el primer congreso que se celebra
después de más de 30 años de paz en una
situación de guerra y la reanudación del
Estado armado
el evento se celebra en el campamento de
refugiados de daila en Argelia principal
Aliado del frente polisario decidirán La
estrategia militar para la nueva etapa
de guerra con Marruecos iniciada en 2020
Y si Ibrahim Gali seguirá siendo el
secretario general
que el congreso sea un éxito y destacado
gracias a la lucha del pueblo saharaui y
su lucha contra la colonización
el fin del alto el fuego se produjo
después de que Donald Trump ex
presidente de Estados Unidos reconociese
en 2020 la soberanía marroquí del
territorio
una polarización internacional que
culminó con la ruptura de relaciones en
2021 entre Argelia y Marruecos después
de que rabat además hubiese apostado por
recuperar la diplomacia con Israel
Marruecos y el frente polisario luchan
desde el 1975 cuando España se retiró
del territorio en 1991 la ONU dispuso un
referendo por la firma del alto del
fuego pero nunca se llevó a cabo
Marruecos que controla el 80% del
territorio propone una autonomía con el
objetivo de mantener Bajo su soberanía
un desierto rico en fosfato y aguas con
abundante pesca